jean eric branaa maître de conférences à
l'université de panthéon assas et
spécialiste des états unis monsieur
branagh bienvenu merci d'être en direct
avec nous alors cette menace de donald
trump à l' oms est ce qu'on doit la
prendre au sérieux
on doit la prendre au sérieux comme
toutes les menaces de donald trump
chinon nous à chaque fois qu'il nous a
averti qu'elle ait quitté une
organisation internationale
beaucoup ont espéré ont pensé et ont
expliqué que ça ne m'est pas arrivé mais
aussi les intérêts des états unis vous
pousse dans ce sens là bien sûr qu'il
prendra la décision à la question de
savoir ses caisses que l'om est sa porte
de plus aux états unis et la réponse est
dans la question puisque donald trump a
expliqué que les états unis n'avaient
pas pour leur argent que les
contribuables n'en avait pas pour leur
argent et donc qu'il n'y avait pas
réellement d'intérêt à poursuivre la
collaboration en réalité à chaque fois
il ya une remise en cause des
organisations extérieures parce qu'elles
expliquent aux états unis comment il
doit fonctionner que donald trump
explique explique lui que il doit
prendre les décisions tout seul comme un
grand sans avoir d'influencé extérieure
alors donald trump qui cherche à avoir
des intérêts en collaborant avec l'om
mais c'est pas vraiment le but
d'ailleurs pékin et si même que donald
trump utiliser agi pour se soustraire
justement à ses obligations vis-à-vis
des ms oui et où le tout le noeud du
problème est là depuis le début de cette
pandémie
l'impression est que l' oms a prêté trop
d'attention à la chine ou en tout cas
aux paroles de la chine qui expliquait
qu'elle était dans la transparence et le
ms répété qu'elle était dans la
transparence alors que peut-être en tout
cas sont des voix qui s'élèvent
aujourd'hui il aurait fallu aller
vérifier davantage sur place puis il ya
toutes ces décisions à contre-courant
quand l'om est fin janvier a annoncé que
la liberté de voyager pouvait se
poursuivre sans aucun problème alors que
donald trump et il le dit souvent à ce
moment là a stoppé le
arrivée des chinois sur le sol américain
n'a pas pour autant arrêter les voyages
contrairement à ce qu'il dit puisque les
américains avaient le droit de faire des
allers-retours encore 100 sans problème
et puis surtout ce qu'il nous dit plus
c'est qu'en janvier et février il a
beaucoup loué l'action du jean ping qui
le disait lui aussi être une bonne
action dans la transparence et qu'il
avait entièrement confiance à lui donc
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe en réalité
c'est une affaire de circonstances il
essayait de désigner la chine comme
coupable de tout
cette crise est bien sûr ça change bien
les perspectives alors donné un autre
enfin quelques films d'être responsable
de tous les maux en tout cas c'est son
avis qu'on éthique la population
américaine à la population américaine
elle est pas encore dans ce débat là
elle est longtemps elle ne suit plus ou
moins en tout cas les républicains
suivent les traces de donald trump
puisqu'il explique que tout vient de
chine alors pourquoi pas après tout et
il ya eu quand même de très nombreuses
déclarations en commençant à parler de
l'origine de ce virus dans un
laboratoire en étant assez flou pour ne
pas dire s'il avait été fabriqué s'il
était passé par là s'il s'était enfui en
france et on sait pas trop en réalité ce
qu'on va retenir de cette séquence c'est
qu'on a encore une fois une un combat
entre le bien et le mal le bien étant
aux etats-unis le mal à l'extérieur il y
à une attaque forte sur les états unis
il faut donc un coupable coupable le
plus ou moins visibles comme l'attaqué
de l'est mais bien sûr en désignant une
puissance extérieure
eh bien on a un effet de rassemblement
autour du drapeau un effet de
patriotisme comme à chaque fois et ça
fonctionne pas mal puisque ces derniers
jours donald trump est monté assez
fortement dans les sondages alors très
rapidement donald trump qui prend de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine depuis dix jours
fous conseils avertis
manifestement de son médecin est-ce que
donald trump n'est pas un peu en train
de faire cavalier seul il est surtout en
train d'envoyer un message à
contre-courant des autorités sanitaires
comme il l'avait fait au début de la
crise d'ailleurs souvenez vous en
février il expliqué tous ses étés à toc
chargé de lui voler le pouvoir
aujourd'hui il va encore alors
entre des scientifiques dont pour
montrer qu il a l'intuition qu'il est
différent des autres il est reparti en
campagne c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
de cette séquence
et il reprend les vieilles les vieilles
ficelles de 2015 à savoir qu'il est
différent les autres politiciens et que
lui à 1 et plus sain que les autres et
qui sait où sont les bonnes solutions
merci jean eric branaa je rappelle que
vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université panthéon assas pas les deux
spécialistes des états unis merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct